okay it's after lunch this is the best
to have because I know you
right now I'll try to be as entertaining
as possible I'm here to talk about
delegates and the reason I talk about
delegates is because it's one of those
things that was difficult for me to
learn as a developer but once I finally
got it I'm like these things are really
awesome they're really useful so I try
to help people get over that hurdle
we're going to be looking at kind of
some basics of delegates but then we're
going to ramp up and kind of look at a
lot of the features that are out there
you know it's and just as a warning for
those of you who don't know delegates
are kind of a gateway into functional
programming so if you're afraid of
functional programming you might not
want to sit around for this talk
otherwise it'll make you excited so if
you're looking for these slides you can
go to my website Jeremy bytes calm and
feel free to tweet it awesome things
about me as I'm doing the talk if you'd
like to tweet not awesome things about
me please come talk to me about it
because I'm always trying to improve so
with that let's go ahead and get started
now the first thing that we have a
problem with delegates is kind of
understanding exactly what it is so I
start out with a definition that
actually comes from the Microsoft
documentation and a delegate is a type
that defines a method signature that
takes a little while to wrap your head
around because if you're a c-sharp
programmer and you're kind of used to
well yeah I understand types you know
we've got classes they've got properties
and they've got methods and all these
other things we've got structs value
types we've got stuff like int and list
of T and all that cool stuff there's I
understand types but this isn't quite
like those types instead of this being
something that's like holding data and
has functionality all it does is
represent the signature of a method so
it's something that we can actually
assign to and later on we can invoke any
methods that are hooked up to a delegate
but it's it's kind of odd and like I
said it took me a while to wrap my head
around that now we might say well what
do we care about delegates well there's
a lot of cool features and there's a lot
of places where we find them already
one cool feature of them is the coupling
code and we're going to be looking at
that today so they actually allow us to
kind of easily implement the strategy
pattern which sounds a lot smarter than
it really is what we'll see it's just
like choosing what we want to do later
it's kind of what that means it also
helps us with because we can use methods
as parameters and like I said kind of a
gateway into the functional programming
world these are what are known as
higher-order functions where we actually
have methods that take methods as
parameters and it's actually kind of a
cool thing now they have a cool
capability which is called multi casting
and I'll show you what that is because
that's really cool and then also if
you've ever used an event handler you've
already used a delegate without even
knowing it because event handlers are in
fact just special kinds of delegates
their delegates that have a few more
restrictions on them and then the most
awesome thing in c-sharp is link
language integrated query
I love link link is amazingly awesome I
also love lambda expressions as you'll
see as we go and the thing is you know
we've got all these cool stuff that we
can look at but we're not going to look
at them in slides because I'm not a big
fan of slides in fact that's my last
slide
it's that okay with everybody I love
code I love showing things in code so
we're going to spend the rest of our
time in a visual studio now the first
thing I'm going to do is wow you with my
amazing UI development skills trust me
just hang on to something
come on visual studio I know you can do
it I always get concerned when it like
says rewriting component cache
it's like didn't you do that earlier
come on you can do it I'm pretty sure
Visual Studio can do this so in the
meantime I think I have some shadow
puppets that I can do come on okay I
like that much better so let me run this
application before we look at what's
inside of it because again I want you to
be amazed at my UI skills now this is
WPF because I love sam'l sam'l is an
awesome UI development tool and as you
can see on the left hand side we have a
list of data items these are person
objects which we'll see in just a bit
and for those of you who have been like
yeah it's been kind of a really long
week so far and I'm kind of tired after
lunch if you want to give up on the
delegates talk I'll give you a little
challenge figure out what my data set is
but you're not allowed to use any
internet-connected device for that so if
you can figure out what my data set is
please come talk to me afterwards
because you're the kind of geek I want
to hang out with but what we're going to
do is we're actually going to work with
this data by just doing some processing
with it and we'll see how delegates work
by doing this so you can see we've got
some radio buttons here that we can pick
and we're going to put some output data
in that box on the left hand side we
also have some actions with some
checkboxes and right now this process
data button doesn't do anything this is
what we're going to fill in so first of
all let's take a look at our data class
which is called person and it's an
amazingly simple class it has four
properties and a two string method so
it's just got the first name a last name
a start date and a rating so that's just
the shape of our data and then I've
overridden the default two string so
that we can kind of give a nice format
if someone just is to string on this now
what I want to do is I want to be able
to output different strings you know
different ways of outputting this
particular class without having to go in
and write a whole bunch of different
methods inside this class and so the way
I'm going to do that is by using a
download
now a delegate like I said is a type
that defines a method signature so what
I want if I wanted to for example have
something they could do this to string I
could write a method that takes a person
object as a parameter and returns a
string that's a pretty simple signature
so I'm going to write a custom delegate
for this just to start out with so I'm
going to say public we'll make it a
public delegate delegate and it's going
to return a string we'll go ahead and
call this person formatter and it will
take a person as a parameter which will
just call input so if you notice here I
just have a method signature there's no
method body all I'm saying is I'm
creating this custom type and this
custom type represents a method that
takes a person as a parameter and
returns a string now you might say
what's the use of this well now I can
create a custom to string method really
really easily in my class so what I'm
going to do is just create another two
string here so we'll say public return a
string called two string and this is
going to take a person format or
delegate as a variable so basically what
we're going to do is pass a method as a
parameter to another method now why do
we want to do this well you'll see why
we want to do this in just a bit for now
inside the body of this method I need to
run this method that's hooked up to it
and that's known as invoking the
delegate so I can say formatter
invoke and then if you notice down here
when we the parameter that they invoke
once is a person object and that makes
sense because again we need a person as
a parameter and we're going to return a
string here now since we're inside a
person class I'm just going to use this
as the parameter so you're going to use
whatever objects that we're currently in
and then again this does return a string
so that means that we can just return
the output of this for our two string
method and so basically what we're going
to do is run the delegate and
turn whatever string that delegate
method gives us back why would we want
to do that I keep asking that question
well let's do something with it so that
we can see why now for this I'm going to
flip to the code-behind of our form just
to keep things simple I just have
everything in the code behind so that we
can focus on delegates and not
necessarily you know gigantic cool
architectures for complex applications
and you can see I have this process data
button underscore click event handler
here and right now it's just clearing
that output list box so what I want to
do is I want to use that to string
method but in order to that use that to
string method I'm going to need
something that matches that delegate
well first let me go ahead and and a put
in a for each loop here so I'm going to
loop through each person in our list box
so we've got the person list box type
items and then I have this add to list
method which we can see down at the
bottom which will just add items to our
output list and this wants a string so I
could say person dot to string and that
would just give us the default to string
method on the object but we have an
overload that says hey we can pass in a
person formatter variable here okay how
do we pass in a person formatter
all we need to do is create a method
that matches that method signature so up
here I'm just going to create a private
method that returns a string so again it
has to return a string take a person as
a parameter I'm going to call this
output last name it's going to take a
person add as a parameter input and then
we're just going to return input dot
last name are you guys horribly
impressed with my coding skills yet
trust me it does get better I hope
so now that I have this I can actually
call I can actually pass this method to
my to string method that I have down
here so I'm going to loop through all
the items it's going to call a two
string method passing in this other
method that says here's what you want to
do with this and if I run this right now
and click our process data button you
can see we have the output that's
showing that now that's not really
impressive because this is kind of hard
coded at compile time and if you notice
I have some radio buttons there and I'd
really like to hook those up so I can
change behavior at run time so let's go
ahead and head that direction so what
I'm going to do is create a variable so
we'll then put this at the top which is
of type person formatter so again that's
our delegate type and I'm going to just
call this variable formatter so what
this is is this is now a variable that I
can assign methods to as long as they
match our delegate signature so again
take a person as a parameter return
string so that means down here in my
code rather than using output last name
directly we can say formatter
equals output last name so again assign
it to the method we want to use and then
pass that variable in now this isn't
real exciting all I did was create an
intermediate variable but what we can
see is that our code still behaves the
same way at this point but now that I
have that intermediate variable it would
be real easy for me to just figure out
that I want to find one of four or five
six seven different methods as many
methods as I'd like to it so in this
case I want to create some methods that
we can use so I'm going to add a new
class and we'll call this formatters and
this will be a public static class and
it will have some public static methods
in it now these public static methods
will need to match our delegate
signature again take a person as a
parameter return a string so we'll
create a public static method that
returns a string I'm just going to call
this one default pass in a person and
this one you guys are going to be really
impressed with this this is just going
to call the no parameter to string
message Wow I see a lot of really
excited people out there yeah there's at
least one now lucky for you you don't
have to watch me type the rest of these
unless you want to watch me type anyone
once we type C the thing is if I have to
type big blocks of code I'll start to
tell really bad jokes and you guys
really don't want to hear that so what
I've just pasted in is a set of four
methods that all match our delegate
methods signature so we can see they all
take a person as a parameter and they
all return a string but they all do
something from slightly different so
again that first one there we're just
going to do the default that's on our
person class the second one here called
last name to upper that upper case is
the last name hopefully that's kind of
self-explanatory first name to lower
we'll go ahead and lower case the first
name and then I have full name down at
the bottom and this will do last name
comma first name and so that's okay for
most Western names for Eastern names
that doesn't work out too well but I'll
leave localization up to you so now that
I have these four different methods that
match the method signature I can assign
any one of these to my delegate variable
that I have and what that means is I can
hook that up to the radio buttons that I
have in my UI and this is where things
start to get really cool so I'm just
going to create a little method here
private void called assigned delegate
and what we're going to do in here is
we're just going to assign one of these
values to the formatter variable that we
have now again I won't make you watch me
type in all this code
unless you want me to anyone yeah thank
you and so basically what I'm doing is
I'm looking at okay apparently I need
with something different
fine actually I like format person
better I'm going the other way okay so
what I've done and this assigned
delegate is based on the various radio
buttons we have so I have a default
string button a last name string button
the first name string button a full name
string button based on that I'm just
going to assign one of those formatter
methods to my delegate that I have here
you guys following me so far this is
where things now start to change at
runtime because instead of assigning
this format person directly to this
output last name method that I have here
I'm going to call a sign delegate and
what that will do is that will look at
the state of our UI elements and decide
which thing we want to do in fact we'll
go ahead and just get rid of that output
last name completely now when I run the
application will see that our radio
buttons actually work so if we click on
the process data button the default
again is the default to string that we
have on the person class if I click on
the last name now we get the last name
to uppercase first name is first name to
lowercase and full name is last name
comma first name that starts to get
really interesting when we think about
what's actually happening here because
if we go back to our code and look at
our person class what this has given me
the ability to do is change the behavior
of my person class without having to
change the person class itself it's
given me an extensibility point
and if you're one of those solid design
principles people this is an example of
the open-closed principle it's open for
extension but closed for modification so
I can change how this class displays
itself when I call to string without
having to change the class itself now
this class is pretty simple but we could
also argue that this is an example of
the single responsibility principle as
well because we could say okay what's
the responsibility of this class what is
its reason to change well it's not doing
much right now granted but probably its
primary responsibility is holding the
data holding those fields that it has
its responsibility isn't figuring out
what format it should output itself in
that should be somebody else's job so
this gives us a really easy way to do
that and when I first saw this I'm like
this is really really cool Wow and then
I think I mentioned that I might talk
about the strategy pattern this is a
very simple implementation of a strategy
pattern too so if you're one of those
people that are looking for those kinds
of elements and saying oh that's curious
maybe I can use that in the future
delegates are a really awesome way that
we can get there now if you notice I
created a custom delegate now you
probably didn't notice that but my
custom delegate is called person
formatter and that's actually a custom
type that I created just like my person
class is a custom type that I created
but I don't have to create custom types
for delegates because the dotnet
framework has these really awesome
built-in delegate types called funkin
action has anyone seen func well yeah
I'm sure you have so func is awesome
but the first time you see it you're
like I have no idea what this thing is
so I'm going to go to help because I
read documentation for some reason I'm
just going to type in func of T well
grab this one func of TT result and all
this is it's a built-in delicate type
that uses generics so if we look at this
we'll see how func of key T results now
T is the argument it's kind
to tell but those are just parentheses
so there's t argh that's the parameter
that this method takes and T result if
we can see is actually the return type
that's coming back from this funk so
basically this can represent any method
that takes one parameter and returns a
results that means that I can get rid of
my custom delegate type and use this one
instead now before I do that I want to
show how related these are I'm just
going to copy this code and paste it
right underneath my custom delegate and
then get rid of some of this white space
here and just show how these things line
up because again the first time I saw
func I was like yeah I'm not exactly
sure what this thing is but it's just a
custom delegate or a built-in delegate I
should say that has generics so we can
see our instead of having string we have
T result so again we can put in whatever
type we want there and then for the
parameter instead of having person we
have T and so that means that we can
pick any type that we want for that so
that means is instead of creating this
custom type I can use this built-in one
and that's what I'm going to do I'm just
going to delete a custom delegate type
now you'll notice my two string method
is no longer happy but all I can do is
replace this with func of person string
and this has the same method signature
so again looking at the two generic type
parameters that we have there the first
one is the parameter so again person is
the parameter the last one is our output
so that's our string coming back from it
now notice nothing else in this code is
complaining it's like that's fine
take a person as a parameter return a
string I totally understand that how
much code do we need to change on the
calling side well it turns out not much
this person for matter field that I have
here he's no longer happy because this
custom type doesn't exist but if I
change this to a func a person string
now everybody's happy again and I don't
have to change any of the other codes so
I can rebuild I can rerun the
application and we'll see that it
behaves exactly the same way so there's
our last name or our default our last
name - upper first name - lower and the
full name so it still all works exactly
the same way now there's a couple things
that I like about using funk I mean
there's nothing that stops us from
creating custom delegates but funk is
built-in so I like to use stuff that's
already there if I don't have to create
something that's better
there's also something that's a little I
don't want to say esoteric but if you
have to custom delegate types even if
they have the same method signatures you
can't directly assign them to each other
you have to do some casting and taste
Andrew knows how to do that because he
was just showing you that in the case of
funk I can assign anything to this that
matches this method signature so again
it takes the person as a parameter
returns a string and that's why all of
our stuff still works now from a
practical standpoint as a programmer I
really like this as well because let me
come back down to this to string method
now if you remember before when I did my
little pop-up to say hey what parameters
does this to string method take well
before it said this takes person for
matter if I don't know what that is I
have to go look it up I have to say Oh
person formatter takes a person as a
parameter returns a string but if I look
at it when it's using funk right here it
says this is a funk of person string
that gives me all the information that I
need in order to use this function
because it's like okay I just need a
method that takes a person as a
parameter and returns a string so I have
all the information here and I love when
code is obvious I hate I hate code that
hides its intention so I really like
this now the cool thing about what's
built into the the framework is that
there's more than just this funk of TT
result there's also
funk of t1 t2 t results so this takes
two parameters and has a return type and
then it keeps going in the dotnet 3.5
world we were limited to this right here
which is a funk of t1 t2 t3 t4 t results
so we could have four parameters and a
return type
now these ins and outs that you see here
these technically has to do with
covariance and contravariance which I'm
totally not going to talk about today
and that's in the generics world but I
use these as a little clue to say is
this a parameter going in or is this a
return type coming out so you can look
at the signatures and see that now
someone decided years ago that 4
parameters might not be enough so we
want to have more and so in dotnet 4.0
we actually got this one I really love
this one this represents a delegate that
takes 16 parameters okay here's a clue
if you have a method that takes 16
parameters please please PLEASE ask a
friend to look at your code I would not
recommend using this now I was really
hoping that in dotnet 4.5 I could have
one that takes 64 parameters but
apparently someone decided 16 was enough
so anyway the correct number is I don't
know how much so we don't have to just
have one parameter coming in in order to
use funk we can use it for a variety of
different situations
now if we look at what we have here in
it so has anyone figured out my data set
yet don't shout it out you'll give it
away I'm going to ask you how many of
them you actually know how many do you
know - there's seven of them out there
anyone know more than two okay talk to
me afterwards so we've seen that we can
easily swap out things at runtime we can
change the behavior of a class without
changing its code I love that kind of
power now you might say are we going to
get into trouble like abusing that power
well if we look at the class that we
have there's really not much that we can
do with it because what we're doing is
we're saying okay this is going to take
a person as a parameter
technically whatever we pass in is
allowed to modify that object so it can
change the properties of the person
class if it really wants to but if you
notice this particular class all of all
of the members are readwrite so they all
have public setters and public getters
so you can change all of those anyway
now if you're more concerned about you
know am I am I able to change the things
that are coming in here
there's ways that you can get around
that so if I were to create for example
read-only properties have a constructor
to populate those then I could actually
make a copy of the object and make sure
that you're not modifying anything
directly but in this case this will work
for what we have now when we look at the
invoke here we are going to add a little
bit of exception handling in a bit but
there's a shorter format that we can use
for this instead of calling invoke we
can just put parentheses directly after
the delegate itself and that will
execute the method now there's times you
may want to use this in times that you
want you may want to use invoke and
we'll see that in just a bit and it's
more for semantics purposes but this
works exactly the same way it will still
invoke the delegates and run the method
that's associated with it
okay so let's move on to the other part
of the UI that I have here this is where
things get this is where you have to
start thinking and it's really cool what
you have to start thinking about because
if you notice I have this action section
here and it's a set of checkboxes and so
if we look at the actions I have average
rating okay so it needs to go through
the items in the list and figure out if
you'll notice there's like 6 out of 10
stars 8 out of 10 stars I want to take
that rating value and get an average for
it for everything that's in the list for
the earliest start date I want to go
through the list and you'll notice these
all have years associated with them and
I want to pick out the year that is
earliest chronologically for the best
commander I want to go through the items
in the list pick out the one with the
highest rating and display that person's
name and then for first letters what I
want to do is I want to go through the
items on the list pick out the first
letter of the last names and output
those to the screen so if you notice I
want to perform some kind of operation
based on the list itself now for this
I'm not going to have any return values
instead what I'm going to have is
methods that just return void but take a
list as a parameter so let's just see
how would I create a custom delegate for
that
well again I could say delegate void
again it returns void and we'll call
this person action and this takes a list
of person as a parameter which we'll
call input so if I wanted to create a
custom delegate this is the signature
that I'd want to use and again I could
take the list loop threw it out put
stuff into my UI my UI output box but
instead of doing that I want to use
another built-in delegate type and that
is action of T now func of T and action
of T are closely related as you might
guess
action of T is a built-in delegate that
returns void so rather than you're
returning a value it performs some type
of action and we can see I've got a
parameter here so returns void takes a
generic type as a parameter so again we
can use this however we'd like now again
in the.net 3.5 world we did have up to
four parameters available and for you
brave souls who are writing really hard
to read code you can't have sixteen
parameters for action as well and so
this is where things start to get
interesting because we're going to have
some nested generics and those kind of
frighten me a little bit especially the
first time I saw this that's why I wrote
out this custom delegate to start with
so this is going to be an action and
we're going to go ahead and call this
process people but I do want a parameter
for this okay now the parameters coming
in is a list of person so I want to have
an action of list of person I love
nested generics it's even better when
you start using tasks because like a
tasks continuation has a parameter which
is a task of action of list of person
the way that I use it so yeah nested
generics are really cool so it does take
a little while to wrap your head around
this but remember kind of the outer
angle brackets that we have there just
say okay these are the parameters inside
and then the list of person just has its
own generic type along with it so let's
go ahead and get rid of this custom
delegate because again we can just use
this class level field that we have and
I want to hook up some methods to this
as well now before that I'm going to do
a little bit of housekeeping because
this code that I already wrote I only
want this to run if our string expander
is open so if our string expander is
expanded go ahead and run this little
block of code that you already ran and
then if our action expander is expanded
we'll go ahead and do something else and
so what I want to do is basically kind
of go through the same process that I
did with our funk I want to go ahead and
create a method that will go ahead and
assign whatever we want to our action
delegate that we have so I'll go ahead
and create another method here called
private void assign action and I'm going
to start out really simply by just
assigning to this process people
variable that we have now one thing that
I love our lambda expressions
does anyone here love lambda expressions
does anybody here hate lambda
expressions that few people Wow if you
hate lambda expressions I have a video
on my website called learn to love
lambdas and so you should go watch that
like immediately because lambda
expressions are awesome and if you go to
my website and follow the links for the
materials for this top you will find
that there okay so I'm just going to use
a lambda expression here to get B I'm
just going to do the first one which is
the average rating that we have for all
of the items that we have on the list so
this is fun I'm going to say P goes to
oh did I leave you already P a bridge R
goes to r dot rating and then we'll say
dot to string and then I want to put
this in the output box so I'm going to
wrap this whole thing in an add to list
Wow okay
when I go lambda expressions I go lambda
expressions hard well let's see what
this does so let's go ahead and collapse
our string Handler and expand our action
now I'm not hooked up to any check boxes
yet in fact I'm not even calling this
method yet am i calling this method
would probably be make things work a lot
better
so can call the assign action and then
what we'll want to do is also invoke
that delegate right so we have the
person formatter delegate that we want
to or I'm sorry process person process
people man apparently I didn't get
enough lunch we have our presses people
a delegate that we want to invoke and
again if we look at the parameter that
this wants it wants a list a person as a
parameter well I have a little method
that will get me the collection of
person objects so I can save our people
equals people get people and so that
give me a list of person objects that I
can pass through here people there we go
so what I'm doing is I'm calling a sign
action and that will assign this add to
list this P goes to add to list to my
process people delegate variable that I
have and then down here we're going to
go ahead and invoke that delegate based
on this people collection that we have
does anyone have any idea what this
might do nobody at all
this is a quiet room don't make me tell
jokes so I click the button and I get
the average rating for my seven items
that I have here with a lot of decimal
places but here's something that's
interesting because if I click the
button again now I have two of them in
my list box I click it again now I have
three of them in my list box Jeremy must
not be clearing out the list box very
well he's pretty bad at that but it
turns out at the top of this method I am
in fact clearing the list box but what
I've actually done is I've used multi
casting without even pointing to it now
you'll notice that in this assign action
where I assigned to this process people
variable that we have
I used a plus equals instead of an
equals now anyone who is hooked up an
event handler will recognize that
because usually if we hook up a button
click event handler in code we say plus
equals and we give it our own method
that's so that we can add our own method
to the event to the event handler so it
will get fired when the event is fired
we can do the same thing with any
delegate variable so what's happening is
each time I click the button it's
calling a sign action and it's adding a
new method to it each time so the first
time I click the button it adds it and
then executes it the second time I click
the button it adds another one and so
then runs both of those the third time I
click the button now there's three of
them in there so that's what's happening
here I had so much trouble getting my
head around the head it's like wow
that's kind of interesting now there is
an easy way around this because inside
our assign action we can just reset our
variables so we can say process people
equals null and so that will clear it
out every time we click the button so
now if we do the same thing we'll only
get at one time
that deserves a little bit of applause
if you have to ask for it it's not
genuine okay I'm going to take pity on
you because I saw some people that
didn't really love delegates or I'm
sorry love lambda expressions so I'm
going to show you how awesome lambda
expressions are by modifying our
assigned delegates that we have here now
if you remember this this is based on
the radio buttons and right now we're
calling the separate methods in this
separate class but what I would rather
do is have code that's like really
obvious and easy to read and for that
I'm going to use a lambda expression now
the problem with lambda expressions is
this right the problem is if you don't
understand them you look at it you're
kind of like I have a general idea of
what's that what that's doing but I
don't know really what it's doing well
the land' expression here is simply
acting as an anonymous method and if our
anonymous method matches the signature
of our delegate we can assign it to that
now all I have to do to kind of get to a
lambda expression is to create an
anonymous delegate instead of a name to
delegate this terminology is really
awesome I love this so what we have
right now inside of our assigned
delegate method this formatters default
format is that last name two upper these
are all named delegates they're
delegates with names
now the terminology does get confusing
because they are also just methods but
it's the delegate again represents a
type that represents the method
signature and then we have variables of
that type and then we assign methods to
that type and it makes my head hurt
whenever I have to think about that
terminology and I've had discussions
with people of like what's the best way
to talk about this stuff and usually
they're like I have no idea so what I'm
going to do is instead of using these
name delegates I'm going to use an
anonymous delegate so if you notice here
I have my default method from my
Matters class I'm going to highlight the
parameters and the method body and I'm
going to copy that code and come back
over here and instead of using this for
matters default directly I'm going to
type in the delegate keyword and then
paste and what I've just done is in
lying to that code and this is what's
known as an anonymous delegate which is
a delegate without a name and so I have
this anonymous delegate here and I kind
of said that lambda expressions can be
used as anonymous delegates din and I so
that means I can turn this into a lambda
expression now if you've never seen an
anonymous delegate turned into a lambda
expression you are going to be amazed if
there's one thing you write down this is
the thing you write down okay so are you
ready I'm going to take the delegate
keyword and delete it and then in
between the parameters and the method
body I'm going to add the equals greater
than sign maybe I'm going to try to add
the equals greater than sign that's our
lambda operator that's it now that's a
lambda expression but the thing is this
isn't usually the way we see lambda
expressions this is way too readable
right I can see the parameter is of type
person and it's called inputs that looks
very obviously like a parameter and I've
got my method body in curly braces well
the thing about lambda spreche ins is
they were designed to be very compact we
got land expressions at the same time we
got link and that's when we're like okay
we want these really short Station's
statements that we can put as parameters
and methods and just have them all in
one spot easy to read without like
blowing up the code so there's a lot of
syntactic sugar around lambda
expressions that allow us to shrink this
down the first one is something called
parameter type inference you should
remember that because if you say it
while your boss is around you sound
really smart all parameter type
inference means is that if the compiler
can figure out the type of this
parameter I don't have to type it in so
I can come up here to this person type
that I have listed and delete it
now this is still strongly-typed
if I put my cursor over input it still
tells me this is a person how does it
know that well because I'm assigning it
to our format person variable and that's
a func a person string so the only thing
I'm allowed to assign to this is
something that takes one parameter of
type person so the compiler already
knows what I'm allowed to assign to this
so I don't have to type in the type
another thing is that if I only have one
parameter
I don't need parentheses around it
another thing by convention is that
because we're trying to make things
compact it's very common to use single
characters for parameter names in my lab
expressions so instead of using input I
might use P now when I'm picking single
characters I try to pick one that
reminds me of what it is since this is a
person object I'm going to use P and
that's to help my brain another thing is
if I only have a single a single
expression that has a return type I can
add that has a that's returning a value
I can get rid of the curly braces and
the return word and that is a complete
land expression and it has the same
functionality as my separate method that
I was calling for matters default now I
know we've known each other for almost
45 minutes now but I also know you don't
trust me so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to comment out the four matters
that default method so that it's no
longer available and I'm going to run
the code and we're going to see that
still works yeah
that's pretty cool okay let me do that
one more time a little bit faster with
this last name to upper so again I'm
going to copy the parameters in the
method body we're going to come over
here and type in the delegate keyword
and paste and again now I'm going to
delete the delegate keyword and put in
the equals greater than sign I can
delete the parameter type since I've
only got one parameter I can get rid of
these parentheses around it by
convention single character parameter
names and I can get rid of the curly
braces and the return keyword that
doesn't seem quite as difficult as it
did before does it in fact once you get
used to this now you can just start
typing land expressions directly into
this so this first name to lowercase
well I can say P goes to P dot first
name dot to lower and down here for full
name I can say P goes to in this case
I'm going to do some string
interpolation P dot last name comma P
dot first name just like that and again
because I know you don't believe me I'm
going to comment out the entire
formatters class we commented out gone
so the only code that I have is the code
that I'm seeing right here and my code
behaves exactly the same way as it did
before so again there's my default two
string last name to uppercase first name
to lowercase full name and when I look
at this code everything I need to know
about it is on this one screen and I
like that I don't like to have to go to
other places to look for code now
obviously it makes sense to separate
things when you've got big chunks you're
trying to make things understandable and
readable but as far as the number of
lines of code that I have here on this
screen I have exactly the same number of
lines that I had when I was using the
for matters class but now I see exactly
what's going on right here next
my code and I really love that so I can
see oh using the default two string oh
it does last name to uppercase first
name to lowercase those were probably
obvious based on the names of the
methods but for full name what is full
name game well here I can see it means
last name comma space first name so I
like having that code directly in front
of me and once you see that again you
kind of get used to it you work with it
for a while and pretty soon something
like this doesn't look quite so for it
now I do have some other I want to hook
up the checkboxes here so I'm going to
go to my snippets I'm going to not going
to make you watch me type all of this
code because this is a lot of code but
we can walk through what it's doing now
since we have let me get rid of my Boop
let me get rid of my taskbar so that
will give me a little bit more space
here lock the taskbar automatically hide
there we go I think I can see the whole
thing oh that's close enough so now I've
hooked up things to the check boxes so I
have the four check boxes now you'll
notice here I don't have you know if
statements that return instead what I'm
doing is I'm using that plus equals
operator for each of these so I can
assign more than one method to the same
delegate variable and then when we
invoke it all of them are going to run
just like we saw three copies of the
same method running we can have copies
of different methods that alright at the
same time now this first one again we've
already seen that takes the average
rating and then outputs it to the list
box that we have on the left hand side
of the screen or right-hand side of the
screen I should say now the second one
is getting the earliest start date so
it's using a min a cool link function on
the start date to string based on short
date format I will apologize for that
format before you see it and I'm adding
that to the output list now this third
one is actually doing a message box dot
show so this is where we want to show
the name of the highest Raider the
highest rated commander
that we have on the list so it's going
to do a little bit of linked order by
descending based on the rating so the
highest one will be at the top take the
first one to string that stick it into a
message box and this last one is
actually going to write to the output
window of our application so it's just
going to do a console dot write and it's
going to take the first character of the
last name and then just kind of append
those together so that we'll see all
seven of those okay let's see how these
work because multi casting man I love
this stuff okay I'm going to do them one
at a time because I'm not feeling really
brave at the moment so there's our
average rating 6.4 okay so we have some
formatting for the decimal places
earliest start date is 10 17 1975 now I
apologize because I am American if you
haven't figured that out yet and so we
do our dates backwards so that's
actually October 17th but we can see
that in the output window and if we were
to look at the items in our list looks
like John Koenig was from 1975 and so
that's his date up there and then for
the best commander again we'll get a
pop-up box which in this case says Dave
Lister and we can see Dave here has a
rating of 9 out of 10 stars and then we
have the first letters of the last names
now I want you to look way down here in
this part of the screen because when I
choose that one loop the output to there
now these are kind of arbitrary actions
I'm performing at the moment but I just
want to show you know K HCl SMG that
represents the last names Koenig hunt
Crichton blister shared in Montana Jambu
okay so I'm outputting all that now
things get interesting when we start
doing this together I'm just going to
restart it so the output submit my
console output clears because let's see
what happens when I start clicking
multiple ones but I'm feeling really
brave I'm going to click all of them so
I'm going to have all four of those
methods run at the same time sort of
it's really easy to think that oh I can
assign like multiple methods to this
delegate and when I invoke it they're
all going to run and it's probably doing
some magic threading on the background
so everything runs at the same time no
it does not do that it actually runs the
methods in the sequence that they're
assigned so the way that I can tell by
looking at this code is if you notice I
did get my average rating I got my
earliest start date and then I got my
message box show which is a modal dialog
which means my application stops
processing so if I were to look way down
here in the corner where I expect to
find the first letters of the last names
I don't see those yet and if I click OK
we'll see those pop up OOP so there's no
magic threading what's happening is the
methods are simply being run in the
order that we assign them and things get
kind of interesting in some other
scenarios but before I talk about that
just to show this a little more clearly
this one that's using that message box
I'm going to move that up in this method
so it's assigned first so now if we do
that same thing what we'll see is that
the message box pops up but because it's
model none of the other methods have run
yet and this is something that's
important to keep in mind because things
get interesting once we start talking
about what happens if you get an
exception in one of these methods well
the default behavior is for example if
the first one gets an exception the
other three will not run that's the
default way that it works now there are
ways around that you can handle
exceptions kind of not by doing the easy
dot invoke but there are ways that you
can get into the method list and you can
go through and loop through it and run
each individually and run each
individually inside a try-catch block so
that if one of them fails you can still
go ahead and run the other ones if you
want some information on that again
follow the links that are on my website
for this talk and you'll see some
articles that I've written about
exception handling using delegates so
that's something to keep in mind so
again
as soon as I click okay now those other
three methods run now there is one other
scenario we need to think about because
what if none of the check boxes are
checked well I get an old reference
exception because if you notice I'm
trying to invoke on this process people
a variable that I have here that is not
populated it's actually not because I
didn't assign anything to it so this is
something else that we need to think
about is how do we handle if someone
gives us a null now there's a couple
ways of doing this let me just show you
what Visual Studio does because the
Visual Studio intellisense and the
pop-up help and the little light bulb
thing get so awesome with each iteration
of this product so what I'm going to do
is I'm going to use the one that doesn't
use invoke and I'm just going to say if
process people is not equal to null then
go ahead and do this now you'll notice
that before we look at why it's grayed
out let me just show you that this
actually does not throw an exception now
because if nothing's checked nothing
runs you know and again these still work
but you'll notice Visual Studio has
grayed out that if line and it's given
me a little pop-up here that says hey I
can make this look better okay go ahead
so what it did was it went back to using
the explicit invoke and then it used the
cool Elvis operator so that's our null
conditional operator so with the
question mark before the dot if process
people happens to be null it's not going
to process any it's not going to run
anything else so process people is no
it's not good to do anything if it's not
null it's going to invoke the delegate
so that's cool stuff and I love how
Visual Studio just says hey do you want
to use this new syntax that you didn't
used to have that's cool I feel really
bad for the resharper guys because every
time Visual Studio comes out like half
of their product is in it right so they
have to keep coming up with new stuff so
this is really really cool stuff that I
like now I could
um you know I'm going to do it I'm
feeling brave I'm going to code up some
more because something that I'm sure you
know as oh oh developers you're probably
not bothered by this but I know there's
some functional programmers in the room
and they're really bothered with the way
that I've been assigning these delegates
and can I can see the look in their eyes
so again I kept this code intentionally
simple so that we could focus on okay
how do these variables how do these
delegate variables work how do we assign
stuff can we do multi casting and all
that but what I would probably do is
instead of having actually the separate
class level field I would make it so
that this delegate would actually reach
our this method would return the
delegate itself so in this case let me
go ahead and move this guy down so that
he's local and we'll just set him to
null to start with boo boo boo boo come
on and then down at the bottom we can
return actually no I don't want to do
that what am i sinking I am over
complicating things all I have to do is
return the land expression because again
these are the radio buttons so as soon
as it hits one of these if conditionals
that matches it should go ahead and
return something appropriate now this is
going to still be upset so I'm going to
return null if it gets past all of those
and so instead of having this oh yeah so
instead of having this intermediate
value I'm just going to return the
delegate itself from this method so just
like we can use methods as returned as
parameters we can use methods as return
types too and that's really cool
so down here I have to get rid of this
format person because this doesn't work
anymore but I could actually just put a
sign delegate right in here I'm not real
happy with the readability for that so
what I would probably do
is a I call this form formatter and then
I would pass this through because I
don't like nesting things too deeply but
that's more style than anything else but
what's happening now is I'm just kind of
passing this delegate this funk a person
string around as a return type you know
into a parameter and this and that and
that rather than having you know these
class level variables which we try to
get rid of anyway and I would do exactly
the same thing with the action so we
could do the same thing we turn that
type okay I'm I'm feeling like I am out
of time so I'm not going to do that one
it would take me two minutes and I have
one minute so what we're going to do is
just do a quick review of why delegates
are awesome hopefully I've convinced you
that it's at least something to look in
a little further and hopefully you're a
little more comfortable with what they
are and how they work in particular funk
and action are amazing you see them
everywhere in Linc and quite honestly
wherever I see a method that takes a
funk or in action as a parameter I treat
that as a big flashing sign that says
put your lambda expression here so I end
up using lambda expressions quite a bit
and again I'm using them just as
anonymous delegates it's not that hard
it's really really cool and I love it it
was a huge hurdle for me it took me it
took me like six months before I really
got lambda expressions but once I did
I'm like oh that's awesome how do i how
do I help other people get that - so
hopefully I've done that today if you do
have any questions feel free to talk to
me I'll be wandering around outside and
feel free to shoot me an email if you
have something that comes up later
because I found that if you have a
question probably other people do too
and so they turn into great blog
articles with that thank you very much
for coming
[Applause]